- When is the last
time you were afraid?
- I'm afraid every day.
- What are you afraid of?
- The health and
well-being of my family.
And I mean for real.
I'm actually more scared
than almost anybody I know.
I've never been
scared in business.
- You're neurotic?
- I'm just genuinely
concerned about
the health and
well-being of my family.
- What are you afraid of?
- Them dying.
I love them very, very much.
I'm being very serious with you.
Like work, never.
- Doesn't stress you out?
- Of course not because
like being the best basketball
player in the world
or at least an All-Star,
it's what I do.
It's what I'm great at.
It's my natural gift.
I'll always win in that.
That's a foregone conclusion.
Whether somebody on
the other side of this lens
likes that or not.
I'm gonna win professionally.
What I'm scared of
is what I can't control.
And the only thing I care about
that I can't control is the
health and well-being
of my family and
closest friends.
- Okay--
- And I'm genuinely
scared of it by the way.
- You are?
- Like it's a thing that crosses
my mind almost daily.
A phone call or text
that isn't interesting at all.
And, you know what?
I'm gonna go
weirdly the other way,
it is the driver
of my happiness.
Because every second
it's not happening
I'm super pumped.
I mean it.
- Oh, I believe it.
- It's very binary for me.